Americans are angry they're upset and
their little fearful we don't have trust
and confidence in our institutions
because of the corruption on Wall Street
and they'll greed and excess and the
cronyism in Washington DC it's our job
to fix the problem my friends and fixing
our economy my friends I like Meg
Whitman the deregulation of the
financial system he is AD regulator
we've got to re-regulate we've got to
re-regulate we've got to re-regulate how
can we trust either of you with our
money it was the fundamental difference
between myself and Senator Obama senator
mccain and i have some fundamental
disagreements on the economy i would
order the secretary of the Treasury to
immediately by up the bed home loan
mortgages in America I'm going to spend
some money on the key issues that we've
got to work on so what one hand giveth
the other hand taketh away that's
fundamental economics Senator McCain and
I actually agree on something you know
like hair transplants I might need one
of those myself